[Music]  Kate Middleton gives birth Prince  William and his wife welcomed their  third child into the world in September  2017 the Duke and Duchess of Cambridge  announced they were expecting another  baby making four year old Prince George  and two year old Princess Charlotte big  siblings and while Kensington Palace  announced in a statement that Kate was  suffering from severe morning sickness  early on in her pregnancy she still  managed to slay the pregnancy style game  one chic outfit at a time the royal  birth comes just before Prince William's  younger brother Prince Harry ties the  knot with former suit star Megan Markel  ety recently caught up with royal expert  Katie Nichol who dished on the actresses  maternal instincts Megan is very doting  with children she's she's very maternal  and she was thrilled to meet George and  Charlotte  [Music]  [Applause]